it's been 15 years since Amanda Ripley's
mother disappeared along with an Austria
she's been looking for answers
ever since look Ripley when this job
came across my desk I read the case
history now a weyland-yutani employee
she discovers that the flight recorder
from the Nostromo has been recovered I
know why you're working in the region
where she went missing
you're still looking
now even though the player spends most
of their time preoccupied with the alien
there are actually other threats aboard
the station that they will have to worry
about Sevastopol station is falling
apart and the population is dwindling
this means there's a lot of people who
are just trying to survive in any way
they can
how do I know I can trust you in order
to tell the story we needed our
characters to be believable so we took
the decision to cast real people
something's something a cost
we worked with a company in Sheffield to
capture the digital likeness of our cast
we really wanted as high a level of
fidelity as possible we want the
characters that you mean on Sebastopol
to look and feel real
much like the original film this is a
credible world filled with believable
characters characters we want to care
about I've been cleared to offer you a
place if you want to come along maybe
there'll be some closure for you